um i think one of the
things that really excites me about web
performance is
you know if you follow people on twitter
you
see you know all these you know
web perf gods talking about
web performance and it seems like it's a
hard thing to do
but it's actually quite easy to become a
web performance
expert at least in your team and i want
to show you how today in just
some really easy steps so thank you so
much diego for the amazing introduction
like uh he said i'm i do a lot of things
i'm currently the ceo of this dot labs
we're a javascript consultancy
um so you know if you need any
javascript
related help or expertise uh we have
some of the most
amazing uh experts on our team and i
just love the community right so i'm
always involved
and i'm always happy to chat on twitter
at lady elite
so we're going to talk about a few
things today um
you know some of the things we're going
to talk about are just simply measuring
web performance
the right way also how to create a
simple foundation for web performance
and what you should be thinking about
we'll also be talking about how to
accurately measure web performance in
devtools and lighthouse
and then also go through some key
lighthouse metrics and then i'm going to
leave you with two just really easy web
fixes that you can simply do when you're
asleep which i love
so let's talk about what perf
so you might have already you know
opened up chrome devtools at one point
in time
and ran a lighthouse report but there is
just
so much to understand and if you do that
without kind of knowing how to
set things up you could potentially be
giving
getting misleading metrics right so
let's go ahead and get started
the first thing you want to do even
before you start measuring
is make sure you understand your users
and your customers
alex russell who is known for web
performance at google
he recommends that you look at the high
percentiles of slowness for your
customers
and if you can't get good population
level data
then assume you're making tech for the
disenfranchised
so once you decide on a specific
demographic that you're optimizing for
right then it's really important to kind
of start creating your foundation
for web performance so the first thing
you need to do is just make sure you
define your goals it's super important
to measure the right
thing and every company has different
goals don't let other metrics define you
or define what your goals are or what
you're optimizing for
the second thing you want to do right
once you know what you want to do
is create a baseline set of metrics that
is so you have something to actually
measure from
and then what you can do is decide which
levers you want to move on and what
numbers you want to improve
the third thing is going to be making
sure you're measuring across multiple
devices
right you never just want to measure on
your machine if you don't have access to
multiple devices
uh tools like chrome dev tools for
example allow you to simulate various
devices which comes in really handy
and then you know this is a lot it might
seem
like a lot to think about right and
maybe you can't get enough
data on that or maybe you just want to
start somewhere so if you just do need
to start somewhere
then just assume you're building tech
for the disenfranchised
so now that you've you know created a
foundation
you're ready to get started so let's go
ahead and get measuring
um in these next few slides i'm going to
walk through kind of
what we typically measure um
when we measure the performance of sites
across the web
a lot of what i'm showing you is kind of
like
unofficial or official industry standard
and a lot of what i'm showing you also
is based on opinions that we have formed
based on the work that we've done at
this dot
so let's talk about just simply
effectively measuring web performance
using chrome dev tools in lighthouse
there's definitely a few steps that most
don't consider
before measuring performance and before
running a lighthouse report
so let's go ahead and go through this
first so the first thing you want to do
is make sure that you
are opening your production application
not dab not local
in an incognito window and this is uh
really key to making sure that any
extensions are not getting in the way
of your measurements and also making
sure you know you're testing best for
what a user would see or
a user experience would be the next
thing you want to do is you want to
change the device you're measuring
in dev tools to moto g4 this tends to be
the industry standard
from what i've seen when running
performance benchmarks on sites
so next up you also want to make sure
you're throttling your network right
i mean of course your site is going to
be fast on a high-speed connection
but this is not typical of a lot of the
users out in the wild
so you need to make sure to throttle
your network speed to 3g
and then uh you know most people are not
running on
super computers that some of you may be
developing on so making sure you're
throttling your cpu down to 4x slowdown
so that you can accurately benchmark
your site out in the wild
now another thing to really remember is
that you need to make sure you're also
disabling your cash in the network tab
otherwise your site is just going to
it'll be cached and it will just appear
faster than it really is
for users who have never been to your
site right
now after this step finally you're ready
to get started measuring so hit refresh
and then that way you can hit your site
with no caching
and after all of this is set up right
and you have all your settings right
um now you can accurately run a
lighthouse report
that's going to give you a realistic
benchmark and or also run other
performance tests within your within
chrome devtools
so here's all the steps again to follow
before you actually begin measuring
in dev tools and lighthouse
so now that you've run a lighthouse
report the next question is
how on earth do you understand those
metrics in your report right so i'm
going to just walk you through a few of
those key lighthouse metrics
um here are six of them so we have first
contentful paint
largest contentful paint cumulative
layout shift that's one of my favorites
um total blocking time time to
interactive
and also the speed index
so a lot of this content is really
amazing
in terms of what you know google and
um mozilla have provided for us as
developers out there
um but you know if you want to learn
more about some of these things
make sure to check out uh web.dev
i put it below as well um
in the last little section right here
you'll see it um so that you can find
out a little bit more about
these different metrics another great
thing about it is that
uh you know the documentation goes into
a lot of detail it's like multiple pages
per metric so it's it's really useful
so the first one is first contentful
paint right and i put the description
uh that web.tab gives you over here but
really first contentful paint is simply
how long is it going to take before a
user actually sees
anything right and one thing to remember
when you're looking at your first
contentful paint is
it should be within 1.5 seconds
um that's what uh google and lighthouse
recommend
the second one is going to be largest
contentful paint
and basically this one is hey how long
is it going to be before a user actually
sees the largest thing that loads on
your page
in the viewport right which is you know
supposedly the most important thing
right
um so this should actually occur within
two and a half seconds of a page
starting to load and you know uh
google recommends that you have a
threshold to measure like the 75th
percentile basically
um of page loads and segmenting that
across mobile and desktop devices
cumulative layout shift as well um again
i think this is one of my favorites
because
uh you might not think about this but
basically any time the browser has to
resize
or move or recalculate layouts on a page
right it's obviously not a great
experience for the user to see things
like jumping around on a page um but
also
it's hindering your performance because
you're having to
like make the browser do work for you
right so your cls score should be
less than 0.1
and again just me making sure that
you're measuring the 75th percentile of
page loads
um and doing this across mobile and
desktop devices
time to interactive um this
is going to be just the amount of time
your site takes to allow users to
interact with it
so making sure you're minimizing the
difference between that first contentful
paint the first time somebody sees
anything on your page
between that and the time to interactive
because one thing you don't want is for
people to see things on your page but
then try to click something and it
doesn't work right because the time to
interactive is not there so making sure
that
fcp and tti are like in sync with each
other
total blocking time so total blocking
time is simply like
the difference between the first
contentful pain and the time to
interactive
again it's that waiting time that you
have right
so how long does the user have to wait
again before like they see something on
the page and then
they're able to actually interact with
it um
sites should always make sure to have a
total blocking time of
less than 300 milliseconds when they're
testing on
average mobile hardware
and last but not least is going to be
speed index so
this is simple it's just how fast does
your site actually look
right you should aim for a speed of
index of between 0 and 4.3 seconds
and that will give you a lighthouse
score of between 75
to 100. so
hopefully going over some of these
metrics in lighthouse help you
understand better like
what performance metrics are important
in your application
and what you can start looking for today
that being said there's also super easy
things you can do to improve web perf if
i had
a longer talk i would go through so many
but i'm just going to give you two that
like you can literally probably do in
your sleep right
so the top two things i want to focus on
are just large images and unused
javascript so images if you look
for web performance content out there i
swear
maybe 75 percent of it is just talking
about images right
um unoptimized images are a huge
problem that is making the web really
slow
um the great part about lighthouse it
actually tells you how big your images
are and what you can reduce
um you know making sure
you know one thing you can do also is
just to make sure that you're loader
loading different size images
depending on the device that the user is
using
making sure that most of your images if
not all are under 100 kb
and also using um source set right
setting the source using source set in
image tags for browsers that can
actually support it
so the great part about source set is
that you can define different sizes of
an
image and just let the browser select
the image based on
the size image source based on the size
another really easy thing to do is just
getting rid of your unused javascript
um lighthouse again to the rescue
fortunately just gives you a list of
unused js on your website so you can
just go down the hit list and fix your
site
this again is one of the things i just
love about you know web performance it
doesn't have to be
a hard thing to do you can run a
lighthouse report
run it accurately and any developer like
you know you have six months experience
one year experience whatever it is
can probably get productive pretty
easily with this stuff
um so another thing you can look at when
you're talking about unused gis
is just looking at the usage physic
visualization
so i outlined the um the steps here
but basically you just go to your
website um
go to devtools go to the console hit
more tools and then click
coverage you hit record you start using
the site
stop recording and then just look at the
results based on the usage visualization
and it will tell you how many unused
bytes per resource you have
so that's a really interesting and
simple thing to do
um whoops i went the wrong way
okay so i know this was a really quick
talk and i wasn't able to go into
everything but i do want to mention some
caveats
so lighthouse reports are not everything
i mean you should definitely be
optimizing your metrics and performance
based on your company's needs and goals
or the goals you want your users to do
without understanding what you're
optimizing for and just
micro optimizing for a good lighthouse
score because there's so many hacks you
can do right to get a good lighthouse
for
um it may end up actually hurting your
goals versus helping
so the real question is should you be
optimizing for a lighthouse score of 100
and i'm gonna say
it depends but if you really want to
thankfully again thank you google um
you can look at this really awesome site
that actually tells you uh
how like how scores are actually
calculated
based on uh your device so it's google
chrome dot github dot io slash
lighthouse
scorecalc and it'll give you um all the
different
uh scorings
so we learned a few things today i mean
measuring web performance the right way
creating that foundation how to
accurately and effectively actually
measure
uh web performance in devtools and
lighthouse we talked through a few key
lighthouse metrics and hopefully the two
easy web prefixes i shared
will help you in your journey as a
developer
so i welcome you to come hang out with
me either on this.media or this.labs
we host free events and tons of content
on this.media so you can find us on
twitter
uh check out all the cool things our
team is doing we host
free training once a month called
javascript
and if you're interested in working with
us you can always check out
this.labs.com
uh you know we have some have had some
amazing clients like google wikimedia
twilio cloudnarybill.com etc
and we just love helping working work
with teams and help
helping them get to market faster so
i hope to see you on the internet
sometime
soon and thank you so much uh jscon from
mexico for having me